arrepentimiento pero no disculpas el rey
felipe de bélgica mostró pesar por la
colonización pero no llegó a pronunciar
el esperado perdón
el poder colonial tal como lo era se
basaba en la explotación y la dominación
esta institución se basaba en una
relación desigual que no podemos
justificar marcada por el paternalismo
la discriminación y el racismo
[Música]
el gobierno de la república democrática
del congo ha visto con buenos ojos la
visita como una oportunidad para
construir una nueva relación
el pasado es a la vez glorioso y triste
diario pero el objetivo aquí es
construir algo nuevo y sobre todo algo
definitivo que sea constructivo para
nuestros dos países
en 2020 en una carta el rey felipe se
convirtió en el primer monarca de
bélgica en mostrar arrepentimiento
un primer acto simbólico antes de esta
primera visita república democrática del
congo desde su llegada al trono en 2013
este miércoles visitó un monumento a los
veteranos de guerra y condecoró a un
cabo de 100 años que luchó en la segunda
guerra mundial también devolvió una
máscara de arte tradicional en un gesto
de buena voluntad llevó muchos presos
he querido durante nuestra visita al
museo nacional y en su presencia
devolver esta obra excepcional para que
los congoleños puedan descubrirla y
admirar la
la oposición se ha sentido decepcionada
por la falta de disculpas y espera
también una reparación económica según
estimaciones 10 millones de congoleños
murieron en los 23 primeros años de
dominio belga durante el reinado de
leopoldo segundo quien gobernó la
república democrática del congo como un
territorio personal